ein kanufahrer hat in der donau eine
kinderleiche in einer plastiktüte
entdeckt eine schreckliche entdeckung
diese tüte trieb unweit der staustufe in
vohburg dass es im landkreis
pfaffenhofen mit einem paddel hatte der
wassersportler die leiche ans ufer
gebracht und bitte vor bei dem toten
handelt es sich um einen jungen im alter
zwischen vier und sechs jahren das hat
die obduktion in der münchner
rechtsmedizin ergeben grausam mehr deren
der plastiktüte eingewickelte leichtem
der wahl nach unseren informationen
wurde schon länger im wasser ja und wir
schalten jetzt zu unserem bild reporter
michael schmelzer der nämlich in vohburg
an der donau dort am fundort ist und mit
dem polizeisprecher sprechen kann
ja schon guten morgen nach berlin in der
tat wir stehen hier vor ort infoboard
beziehungsweise in großmehring an der
donau direct seit den frühen
morgenstunden sind hier die
suchmaßnahmen wieder im gange die
polizei und die feuerwehr ist hier mit
booten und tauchern zugange sucht den
nahbereich des ufers ab aktuell suchen
auch kräfte der bayerischen
bereitschaftspolizei
fußläufig den uferbereich ab um hier
vielleicht mehr anhaltspunkte zu finden
um auch diese tat vielleicht ein
bisschen rekonstruieren können bei mir
hier polizeisprecher michael graf vom
präsidium oberbayern nord herr graf die
situation die auffindesituation wie hat
sich das ist für sie der letzten
donnerstag wurden wir verständigt dass
ein paddelboot fahrer hier auf der donau
an der oberfläche treiben des
gesehen hat und dass dann im anschluss
dann auch ans ufer verbracht hat dort
hat sich dann herausgestellt dass es
also anscheinend ein inhalt ist wo man
von organischem material ausgegangen ist
umgehend wurde die polizei verständigt
und dann ging die die arbeit für uns als
polizei los das
aufgefundene
wurde dann die rechtsmedizin nach
münchen verbraucht wird eine obduktion
durchgeführt und das hat sich dann
bewahrheitet beziehungsweise der
verdacht dann erhärtet dass es sich hier
um einen leichnam handelt
eingehen wurde erwähnt dass es ein kind
im alter zwischen vier und sechs jahren
im vorschulalter eine männliche person
ergibt sind da schon nähere hintergründe
der kann man schon mal sagen zu den
fortgeschrittenen ermittlungsmaßnahmen
genau das ergebnis der obduktion war
dass es sich um einen jungen handelte er
im vorschulalter ist zu den ermittlungen
kann ich im moment keine auskunft geben
die laufen auf jeden fall auf hochtouren
wir haben im moment weder einen genauen
anhaltspunkte
wie die leiche des jungen in die donau
verbracht wurde und wir wissen auch
nicht den genauen ort zu den maßnahmen
die jetzt hier vor ort gelaufen was kann
man dazu sagen aktuell heute morgen
haben die suchmaßnahmen also hier im
bereich des auffindeortes haben wir
fortgeführt wir hatten spürhunde im
einsatz die speziell ausgebildet sind
die auf dem wasser unterwegs waren
gleichzeitig suchen beamte der
bereitschaftspolizei hier den
uferbereich nach möglichen spuren und
hinweisen ab wie geht es dann weiter
gibt es denn schon nähere erkenntnisse
hat sich dann schon irgendwas ergeben
für sie im moment wird überprüft ob in
bayern in deutschland oder auch im
benachbarten ausland vermisstenmeldungen
unter umständen passen auf unserem fall
hier ist es aber so dass man hier ganz
am anfang der ermittlungen stehen
wie sich die lage hier vor ort darstellt
also aktuell noch taucher der
berufsfeuerwehr in ingolstadt im wasser
zu gange die suchen den anrufer umfeld
bereich ab ein leichenspürhund war heute
früh von einem boot aus dem einsatz der
die wasserfläche abgesucht hat also
alles in allem hier noch ein
großaufgebot im einsatz und die lage
bleibt weiterhin spannend